I know it sounds crazy but Monkey D GARP
might not be Luffy's only legendary
Grandpa because what if I told you that
his grandfather on the other side of the
family tree was none other than roxty
zabek and I promise that if you make it
till the end of this video you will have
your mind completely blown away by the
conclusion of this also a big thank you
to Reddit user Mr Bushido for laying the
groundwork for this theory on our
subreddit about the secret Goa Kingdom
connection between GARP rocks and Roger
and their brotherly friendship yes I'm
not bullshitting but before we can get
to those crazy parts of this we have to
do some groundwork first because really
we don't know all that much about this
most infamous of all Pirates trying to
conquer the world of One Piece who has
all but been erased from history however
there are a lot of clues about him
including for example his Silhouettes
that should tell us something I mean
lots of theories have drawn the obvious
Blackbeard comparisons teaches giant
raft literally being named the saber of
zebek however if you ask me rox's
silhouette looks a whole lot like
another character that we already know
Monkey D Dragon a lot of fans have long
assumed that monkey the dragon was
garb's son given that he carries the
monkey family name however as you might
have heard before or might not have this
doesn't have to be the case GARP never
once actually refers to dragon as his
quote-unquote son all he does whenever
he talks about him is referring to him
as Luffy's father so Dragon could very
well be garp's son-in-law and Luffy's
mother could then be garb's daughter
because while Luffy strongly resembles
his grandfather GARP those genes seem to
have skipped dragon's generation
completely if Dragon was in fact garb's
biological son so wouldn't it be more
likely that after his father was raised
from history Dragon instead took his
wife's name the daughter of Garb and
Luffy's mother I mean it wouldn't be
even the first time a character has
taken their mother's name in the story
after all Luffy's own brother Ace was
named portgas as a way of separating him
from Roger's lineage for his own
protection and we all know that Oda
loves himself some foreshadowing so
could dragon and then Luffy after him
have done the same in order to separate
themselves from The Rock's family name
and while Dragon of course clearly has
different goals than Garb his vision
does seem to align very well with parts
of Roxas I mean Dragon doesn't appear to
one to claim the empty throne for
himself to become king of the world but
just like Roxy's back he does
specifically want to combat the world
government and the celestial dragons so
could he have inherited this will from
rocks from his father after all the
d-clan are the natural enemies of the
Celeste Steel Dragon as we very well
know from Luffy himself however this of
course wouldn't be the only thing that
Luffy would seem to have inherited from
rox's side of the family for instance we
know that rocks gathered into his crew
the most fearsome and strongest pirates
on the grand line Edward Newgate
Charlotte lindlin sheiky the Golden Lion
even a young kaido and so all of these
Pirates many of whom would later on
become yonko are the strongest forces on
the planet and they all served on rox's
ship and so someone who could rally all
of these incredible personalities under
one flag would have to be supremely
charismatic and Powerful I mean getting
people like that to work together they
would have to have a gift of making
friends and allies out of anyone they'd
meet does that sound like anyone you
know according to mihog Luffy's
propensity for making allies is without
any doubt his greatest strength and this
strength may have come from his
grandfather Roxy's the back in the very
same way that rocks gathered the
strongest Pirates of his era to his side
so Luffy does by amassing his Grand
Fleet and teaming up with several
members of the worst generation law and
kid very much seemed to be set up as
similarly significant members of Luffy's
own pirate era after all but the
similarities between rocks is a back
monkey the dragon and Luffy are
multifaceted not only do they share
physical resemblance all three of them
but they share defining characteristics
as well however of course this is not
where this Theory ends not even close
the ending is going to blow you away so
let's talk about Luffy's family tree
because the family history shared
between the monkey and the Rock's Clans
might go way way deeper so get ready for
some soap opera level of speculation
here and really it all starts with a
young version of GARP nichiroda has a
really tight grasp on his story's
timeline even even when there are
potential loopholes he's pretty good
about closing them and so after he
decided to make Ace the son of Goldie
Roger a move that was most likely not
intended from the beginning he knew it
wouldn't work because Roger had died
before Ace's birth Ergo podcast the
Rouge was pregnant for two years to
avoid the one piece equivalent of King
herod's this is a man who when he
introduced time travel into the series
made sure that it only worked one way so
he wouldn't mess up his precious
timeline here he even uses masterful
hints like having the Samurai and Momo
alluding to knowing Roger allowing
eagle-eyed readers to guess the huge
time travel plot twist here and so given
that Oda has been very meticulous let's
look at Garb in the past because aichiro
Oda has drawn him before when Oda Drew
GARP as a child he looked a whole lot
like young Luffy like look at this he's
a rambunctious Adventurer riding a tiger
he's a wild boy befriend forest animals
just like his grandson did on the very
same island this doesn't look like a
future hero of the Marines to me this
looks like a future pirate now so how
exactly did he go from the spitting
image of Luffy to a noble marine and
even more importantly let's also poke a
little bit at the Timeline he's gotten
he joined the Marines at the age of 22.
we know that Kobe joined the Marines at
the young age of 16. Xavier from Film Z
joined the Marines at age 14 and while
it's not unheard of for the Marines to
join later on in life zakazuki and
borcelino for instance were also in
their 20s when they joined and so I
think it's pretty clear that joining the
Marines wasn't exactly the starting
point for Garth which of course leaves
us with a question what might GARP have
been doing up until age 22. this is
going to be super important for the
crazy conclusion at the end of this
Theory so pay close attention now it has
been repeatedly shown throughout the
story that Luffy clearly takes heavily
after his grandfather so I think it's
very doubtful that GARP was just
patiently sitting around the Goa Kingdom
until he turned 20 or 22 to join the
Marines if he was anything like Luffy as
a kid which the illustrations and the
story would suggest strongly he probably
couldn't wait to get away from his home
Island and see the world but before we
can speculate on what exactly GARP was
doing for all those years let's talk
about the home Island itself a little
bit longer because the Goa Kingdom as
you know is a place of extreme
inequality the Nobles live in complete
extravagance while the poorest members
of the country live among the literal
trash of the gray terminal now we don't
know what exactly it was that inspired
guard to become a Marine in the first
place but his foundation here could have
instilled a desire to create a better
more just World while at the same time
reinforcing his conflicted distrust of
the world Nobles that he carries till
this day Dragon who also comes from
Kingdom sees it as a sort of miniature
version of the entire one piece world
but unlike GARP who wants to improve the
system from within his son or probable
son-in-law Dragon wants to take down the
whole of the corrupt world government
and rebuild a better world by force if
necessary okay and at this point the
story takes a really weird but super
important interesting twist so when
naming the nationalities of the entire
Straw Hat crew if they were real life
people Oda has said multiple times I
think that Luffy would be Brazilian the
Goa Kingdom actually takes its name from
a region of India that was colonized by
Portugal the same European country that
colonized Brazil but what if I told you
that Oda Sensei giving Luffy his
nationality might have actually been one
of the biggest pieces of foreshadowing
in the entire Series so far now you see
it's pretty common knowledge I think
that many one-piece Pirates are based on
and named after real life pirates X
Drake is Sir Francis Drake jewelry
Bonnie is and Bonnie Blackbeard is
Blackbeard huh but one parallel I
haven't heard as much is rocks Rock
seems like an extremely strange name but
there actually was a famous pirate named
this and I know I'm gonna Slaughter this
but I'm gonna try anyway
braziliano in English anyways his name
literally is translated to rock the
Brazilian the Brazilian as in from
Brazil and Rox even shares a few
important qualities with his real life
counterparts because this real-life
version of rocks also sailed with other
very famous and notorious Pirates such
as Henry Morgan Captain Morgan's
namesake for the rum fans in the
audience his first Mage jealous dilica
or Captain yellows became a mighty
pirate captain on his own right just
like the yonko who were spawned from the
former rocks crew and Roque braziliano
even bought his ship from Francois Lolo
name Roto Noah Zorro's namesake
butchering these names I'm so sorry I do
want to say that this part is more of a
fun fact not really part of the theory
because I highly doubt that rocks bought
his ship from a yet to be born Zorro but
it might kind of hint at the you know
Blackbeard naming his ship after rocks
kind of thing now the Brazilian Rock was
famously a bit of a barbaric and violent
drunk but the crucial similarity is in
Rock The brazilian's Fate no one knows
about it there's no record of him after
1671 whether he died at sea or retreated
into a quiet life of anonymity his fate
is to this day unexplained and so
basically just as rocks and God Valley
have been completely viped from the
history books Roque brazilianos and is
shrouded in a lot of mystery so could
rocks be from the Goa Kingdom one pieces
Brazil equivalent and if so then who's
to say that roxt is a back-end Monkey D
GARP met each other on the high seas for
the very first time you know as a pirate
and a Marine I mean it's really hard to
Envision GARP as anything else but the
hard-headed fist of love-wielding marine
that we know and love but could rocks
and him have been friends I mean if they
are from the same Kingdom it would be
believable that two super powerful
people with outsized personalities would
at least know each other if not at least
get along and if GARP shared Luffy's
adventurous disposition could they even
have Voyage together out to sea and so
what if during garb's missing years
before joining the Marines at the age of
22 he was actually a pirate not a
violent Buccaneer of course but a
peaceful and adventurous pirate like his
grandson or if you want to use the
terminology from Ichiro oda's romance
Dawn a precursor to one piece a peace
loving pirate opposed to a violent
pirate which is kind of how he divides
those two groups in the one piece world
as well and of course we already know of
garb's connection to Goldie Roger while
being Fierce Rivals the hero of the
Marines and the king of pirates they
were also so close friends in a way
after all Roger entrusted Ace his own
son and who he probably believed to
change the world into garb's care not
Rayleigh or Shanks or any other Pirates
GARP now we do know that Roger is also
from the East Bloom hailing from
loketown so could these two upstarts
from the Goa Kingdom rocks and GARP have
met Goldie Roger as well on their early
Journeys I know that it sounds
absolutely insane but try to entertain
the idea that before the formation of
the Rocks crew before Roger found the
one piece and before Garb joined the
Marines these three all sailed together
on one ship that they were running
around islands and just having a good
time like Luffy Sabo and Ace the three
could have adventured and saw treasure
and thrills sailing from Island to
Island but eventually something must
have changed a rift that formed between
these three friends and most likely this
conflict was brought on by rocks man
this of course is pure speculation since
we won't know until we finally learn the
truth behind rocks and what happened
between the three at God Valley but it's
very possible that rocks was simply no
longer satisfied with the simple
fun-loving adventuring he wanted wealth
or fame or power and perhaps he would
stop at nothing to achieve those things
he would start to treat others cruelly
he would enact violence on his Rivals
and perhaps even innocent people by the
way you should really subscribe if you
don't want zabek coming for you next and
so it was this great division or Rift
that formed between these three friends
that sent Roger and GARP and also rocks
of course in separate directions as well
Roger insisted that piracy could still
be fine but done in the right way
similar to Luffy he could still
adventure and be free without bringing
harm to others and gathered together
with silver Israelis copper Gabon and
the rest of the Roger Pirates he
circumnavigated the entire Globe
eventually finding love tail GARP
however wanted to protect others from
the harm of violent Pirates like rocks
and thus chose to join the Marines
despite his inner conflict with working
on the celestial dragons he sought to
work within the system to change it for
the better given that Kobe and helmeppo
have joined sword and were also trained
under him garb's a pretty good candidate
for the organization's leader but that's
for another video of course and so these
three went their separate ways but would
of course as you know meet again when
Rox finally set his eyes upon becoming
the king of the world the world
government had to stand in opposition to
him ever since we learned about God
Valley it's been perplexing to think
that Roger and Garb would ever team up
yet alone do so to protect the celestial
dragons I mean GARP is clearly no fan of
the celestial dragons himself and Roger
of course as a pirate didn't like them
either but it might just be that they
weren't fighting rocks to save the world
Nobles at all they were fighting to
prevent a world where rocks held the
power because such a world would be even
worse than one controlled by the world
governments so they went to fight their
former friends as you can see this
Theory suddenly makes God Valley very
personal which I absolutely love Gart
and Roger weren't just fighting a
terrible and Powerful enemy they were
fighting against their closest childhood
friend and technically brother and so
it's really no stretch of the
imagination to think that these three
would have exchanged sake cups just like
Sabo Ace and Luffy eventually would do
as well and I just want you to imagine
how much this would raise the stakes for
an eventual rocks and God Valley
flashback once we get it these three
Legends of the one piece World an evil
pirate a marine hero and the king of the
Pirates might even parallel similar
trios today the new rocks would be
Blackbeard the future pirate king would
of course be Luffy and the Marine hero
role could be fulfilled by mocha or more
likely based on recent story events Kobe
after all Luffy and Kobe have been
friends and allies all throughout the
series even before Luffy gathered a
single member of his pirate crew and so
if it should be true that Luffy is the
grandson of both GARP and rocks this
would mean he inherited the D initial
from both sides of his family tree which
let's be real is very likely the only
other character who's confirmed to have
a d from both his father and motherly
side is Ace clearly they were both the
optimal candidates to become the next
pirate king and the next Joy boy and
this of course leaves us with another
and maybe even bigger mystery if rocks
and garbs are Luffy's grandfathers and
dragon his dad who in the world is
Luffy's mother then and who are his
possible grandmothers as his family tree
seems to become more and more
significant and with Oda Sensei having
confirmed twice now that he has indeed
drawn Luke mother before in the series
shouldn't it be possible to figure out
who that person is yeah it probably is
so click on this video if you want to
watch that